what's happening there reject nation 45
years in the making we have ourselves a
trailer for avatar 2. if you caught our
youtube short we did not watch the
trailer in the theaters intentionally
here we are today if you guys can leave
a like that'd be very much appreciated
let's see what all the glory is
[Music]
and we're back
[Music]
wow
good to see you good day
jake sully
[Music]
wow
nipple chills chills
[Music]
damn humans
wow
wow
[Music]
i know one thing
wherever we go
[Music]
this family
[Music]
wow
here's our fortress
damn that [ __ ] it
so much better yeah and did they let him
have his australian accent
i
don't think so it's not like his actual
voice i guess so yeah because i've
watched this again recently the the
first one on an oled tv on like 4k and
then so it was noticing like yeah the
visual effects still look great but
there are some shading things that they
could definitely do just looking back at
this now i'm like oh yeah they they fix
a lot oh my god the engine's so sunny
like
whatever they used you had to control
the light and the physics in this is is
absolutely gorgeous and that's something
that i remember from the original film
and especially in 3d that's something
that got me excited to see that even
just water is is present in the title of
the movie because one of the things that
worked so well about this the transport
of experience of the 3d in that first
movie was in sequences where water was
heavily prominent or glass or both i
rarely get excited for a 3d movie but
this is one where i'm like i gotta see
that on the biggest and most deep screen
possible well i think they shot this
with imax cameras here's how we
witnessed it i took four seconds of
footage where we had to wait only got a
little bit of a recording there way in
the hallway that's the only way we saw 1
20th of the screen for like five seconds
let's just wait a minute then right back
in here yeah i heard this movie took
forever to get made especially because
of the fact that they are dealing so
much with being underwater and that was
one of the biggest challenges of can
they really handle the mocap underneath
there and they figured out a way to do
it apparently this doesn't really give
you a lot of insight into the trailer
from my understanding that this is going
to be a bit of a time jump where jake
and nathiri they have children now they
have like a whole family like three of
them and they really neglect the first
one very emotionally abusive to that one
but baby gets all the attention the
middle child is like observing what's
going on it's real family comedy
in the middle that's what i'm gonna be
dealing with uh them and then they're
like i think they're looking for a new
home because apparently something
happened in the last movie to their
other oh no
industrialization when will it end these
sons i thought they got rid of them at
the end but apparently they're back you
know the human uh uh spirit will never
stop from trying to obtain unobtainium
so i feel like yeah maybe there's been
like a second wave of people trying to
come and mine and colonize or yeah maybe
there's some kind of other circumstance
but either way clearly we're gonna be
dealing with the same two worlds
colliding here and nobody knows how yet
but james cameron's talked about like
you know we're going to bring steven
lang back so i feel like that whole
organization is probably going to
persist through these four movies or
whatever is planned well it is still
called avatar and it's easy to forget
that the avatar is some type of human
navi gene splice thing that was created
so i wonder what the development of the
actual avatar itself is did they do
something where they were able to get
stephen lang and upload him into an
avatar himself you know
steven blue steven ling i love it make
him blind
crossover yeah you have him and courtney
weaver's supposed to return and james
cameron said that her character would be
returning but then sigourney weaver came
out and that she's playing like a
different character she's still gonna
have that assertive sigourney weaver
classic personality you know that's what
i love about her so it seems like a
woman i would never want to piss off
yeah yeah but like all the other women i
gladly pissed them off any day of the
week
she'll take that respect
yeah so she's going to be returning and
you saw this character featured
prominently in the trailer more than our
returning characters i don't know jake
champions
who's the actor the actor playing this
person yeah who's like born on the can
on the settlements on pandora or
whatever i thought he would be fine then
like if he's body adjusted they show him
with the oxygen mask that they have he's
like the george of the jungle of this
that's right yeah yeah he's gonna be the
new white savior to unite the worlds
together i mean the last movie already
had you know like let's face it the navi
very much inspired by native american
and african culture and then white man
steps in culturally appropriates and
becomes our savior that's right yeah
that's what we do that's why history
loves us yeah it's good stuff dude it's
good this guy you know this other guy
born of the humans but he prefers to
spend time with the navi
well i'm excited to see the the reef
people i'm not even going to attempt to
pronounce their name with an m um
meticulous or something of metals
i think what the the biggest showcase of
this trailer had to evoke are the
visuals gonna look better because that
was one of the biggest things about the
first movie well people would often sort
of pan the story which on my second w i
had only watched it again for the first
time a week ago i actually really
enjoyed a lot and the the story may not
be the strongest part of it and the
biggest part of it is often you know the
wonder the world the aura of pandora oh
oh bars in the cars at the stars
i love seeing you know like yeah the
showing off the development of the
technology that was already so
groundbreaking
and now we'll see here they're gonna do
the high frame rate thing that peter
jackson did with hobbit but good i'm
curious very curious to see because
that's the other impressive thing is is
james cameron seems to find i don't know
if he
specifically looks for stories that
force him to innovate but yeah like i'm
really curious to see how that plays
this time around as well as alongside
the other innovations they had to do to
shoot underwater my favorite aspect of
the original avatar was just that aura
and that sort of beautiful tribal spirit
that really permeates the whole tone
that you can appropriate that i
appreciate more than most people
and i love they need their day in the
sun so let me step in and give it to
them i'm gonna your culture is great i
think i can figure out what we can
really do to make this shine right come
with me let me dress up like you this is
really taking me back to that feeling of
just wonder and transportation
and just this beautiful tribal like
while there is struggle and everything
like that just this looked like the
greatest video game sim i want to get
into vr for well it's funny looking at
the last avatar movie it looks like a
great ps5 video game
and
which is like a great cinematics off of
a video game this looked like a movie
yeah which in 15 years it'll look like a
great ps7 video yeah
well you're like wow the rendering on
siri's face man it looks real
but yeah i'm excited for it i can't wait
to see it all right guys what did you
think leave your thoughts down below you
can subscribe click that bell leave a
like and we'll catch you guys soon